[Music]
foreign
it's hard to hold a whole bunch of sugar
in your mouth
and keep it all in well here's the thing
it starts us off but you get parts
because all your moisture is going to
this thing so your body starts to dry
out so then you start your you basically
holding the sugar uh in your dry them
out at a certain point man you feel like
the desert how old are you I don't know
like he was a child okay like when I was
like eight like eight yeah like yeah
seven eight eleven and 14 even 14 even
and this one 18 year old [__]
we each have this [__] girl who's
probably 14 that went shirtless and she
was like [__] four four to fourteen
shirtless bruh
shirtless why was that I don't know it's
just over the whole family was pretty
much shirtless and they didn't do any
different by the girls man this girl was
shirtless and we all thought like damn
she's like a long hair she's like the
most best looking dude you ever seen
right we thought that till about 11. and
then somebody's like that's the girl man
she just goes shirtless and we're like
and nobody told to put a shirt out in
school or something oh I don't know
about school but uh I never I mean she
was in a children's school I was a
little bit older than her but I never
saw anybody just be completely shirtless
like that there was a little Butch
[__] sugar in them
yeah if I can if it was a cheap game bro
that's like if you don't have a bunch of
money to go do something you feel each
other's mouth up with sugar and then
y'all just gotta slap each other in the
cheek there was a kid in my neighbor
John Carney not a bad kid always great
sent to him but he had a brother Brian
Connie in those days kids didn't have
ADD and they didn't have autism images
and they use the toy troop yeah we call
them God's favorites yeah they used to
make them drink
pissed in a beer bottle and close it and
just put it in the last bottle he would
take it clap his beer and you [__]
drinking
I was never involved in this [__] with
Brian Carney
is he handicapped no he just wasn't
sharp you know was it he just wasn't a
shark kid nice kid always said hello
Brian Connie but they did weird things
to him like they used to make him eat
[__] like they pay him like 15 bucks
to make a needle out of like weird how
much [__] oh I think I'm an actual [__]
no no no no like fill his mouth with
pepper and [__] like that and they had
this other kid the kid the guy who they
just fired from the Miami Hurricanes
defensive coordinator when he was a kid
his brothers and all those guys neighbor
used to tie him up on a bicycle make
them eat raw eggs and blow him up in his
mouth and all that [__] like put the
eggs in the shell and smack him and blow
the egg in his mouth no wonder that when
that guy went to Penn State was an
All-American thank God I would have died
in your town thank God I was too nerdy
for that I would have been one of those
kids the guy I got into it with when I
did that club before I met Lee I did a
club in New York City one of the first
times I went to New York to do comedy on
my own
I booked a music Club in the village
right and I went there the guy that
started a fight with me his name was
Brian Burns and when we were kids when
you were in grammar school he already
had a legend
what he would do is he had a gang of
guys that would take you tie you down
and they would put duct tape on your
balls and [__] that glue [__] from
taping and they would call it a table oh
yeah they would give you a table where
they lay you down and wrap you up with
tape yeah pull the tape off you and [__]
like that he was known for all that
stuff his spraying stuff on your balls
he was a big time bully
and you know what happens to bullies bro
they get beat up later on in line people
and I remember that night like I was
like I could take this [__] damn and
I had already a plan he kept coming into
trying to apologize and I kept going you
know what I could take this guy I could
kick him in the [__] knee you could
see he got like 300 something pounds
so but you felt like so it was crazy
because the Todd had switched with that
dude like it and back in the day he was
a bully yeah he was a bullying kid you
know he was bro when I was in eighth
grade or seventh grade he was already in
high school
torturizing people they said if you play
football be careful
because if something happened during
football practice that you hit him hard
or something he'd get his friends to
give you the table especially if you
were Spanish or something yeah you know
oh that [__] got racial huh it was what
it was yeah I mean it was where the
[__] was I mean we had one Mexican
kid that showed up on our time wouldn't
have any Spanish people we had one
Mexican kid let me think about what this
kid's name was I think it was Nick right
and uh I remember we all had uh science
class and um oh actually in science
class said these hamsters you could play
with until the second bell rang or
whatever then you had to give you know
put them in the cage and everybody could
then we would do learning you know and
this [__] one time they had this
hamster right Superman we named him and
uh and I was holding him in this [__]
big sweatshirt I had right and after
class uh I forgot he was in there he
fell asleep in a little pocket wherever
you put your hands right so that's why I
just throw him a book back I'm running
next you know get in a fight with two
brothers right get beat up pretty good
and one of them had [__] killed this
hamster that was still in this pouch
he'd [__] punched it yeah
so I never had it like sometimes I'll be
got [__] I'm not even joking bro I
have dreams where I feel like I had an
abortion
poor Superman I knew something wasn't
gonna be good I think his name was
Superman let me think for a second it
might not have been Superman why would
you take the [__] hamster out of
class and put it in your [__] pocket
for anyway no no because you were
sitting at class you just nothing to do
and it was nice to kind of have
something before when you go to high
school
next day out of town a couple away from
there called uh Covington Mandeville and
where'd you go to college I went to uh
LSU and uh University of New Orleans
really did you graduate from LSU I
graduated from University of New Orleans
eventually look at you you bad
[__] so we made it through you
went to LSU they still talk about pistol
Peter oh dude the town I grew up in get
the [__] out of here he lived and died
in our town dude get the [__] out of
here yep and Lee Harvey Oswald went to
um went to middle school in our in our
town get the [__] out of here swear to
god dude and I mean I say this a lot but
in 19 uh and once in the 80s and in 1994
a bunch of infected monkeys got out
because Tulane University had their
primate testing facility Center in our
town and I of infected monkeys got out
and they let us out of uh YMCA summer
camp to help the police looked for him
bro I remember they came to summer camp
basically took the kids to look for let
me get that pen real quick not kids
they're the tallest boys
they took the tallest boys right out and
uh and we helped them look for them I
remember surrounding a couple of chimps
outside of a Kenny Rogers Roasters dude
off of Highway 190.
that's a true story dude that's the name
of your book huh I was surrounded some
chimps and next to it Kenny Rogers
Roasters and dude the [__] got racial
like people go around town they were
like yeah and I mean this is [__] up I
mean this just shows you how far in the
South you are people like 90 monkeys
just escaped from this place or whatever
and you literally have like you know
people riding around with guns [__]
Confederate flags it's like dude these
are animals man like relax like the [__]
almost got it was weird like people were
like these [__] monkeys like they'd
planned it like it was crazy like it was
I just proved that name out because
today in today's paper on Twitter
it said that the basketball player from
the Lakers is producing A Pistol Pete
marriage oh that's awesome
and I'm sitting there going you know
what kills me about today is they're
doing biopics
about people that these [__]
don't even know that movie should have
been done 20 weeks after he [__] died
yeah but nobody thought about doing it
you know do you know much about pistol
people I mean I think I know a pretty
good amount about him I mean I know he
played you know I know he played at LSU
I know he played uh for the Jazz
um I know his two sons really yeah they
played ball like whenever I was growing
up so one of them like a little younger
one of them a little bit older
so I mean they were Legends it was kind
of you know it was a small town like it
was Legends yeah the biggest name in
[__] if he lost his father wouldn't
let him sleep in the house and [__]
we'll make him sleep in the [__] yard
this is Southern Basketball Jack dude
they had a half court or a quarter Court
in there upstairs of their house above
the look look in the Attic they had a
basketball [__] around the marriages
didn't [__] around that old man didn't
[__] around that dude it had like that's
why he drank himself to death Pistol
Pete because he there was no childhood
his father made him go out there and do
wind Sprints and [__] yeah and that guy
wasn't fast but his [__] handling
skills were just phenomenal they made up
for it in my life I've seen two people
handle a ball [__] phenomenal one was
a guy named Pistol Pete Maravich who's
an NBA player
and another guy was a kid from
South Carolina his name was Jackie
galloon white kid or black kid white kid
hmm and he played basketball on acid
that's why he didn't get drafted because
he was such a freak but his handling
skills I saw him playing I played
against him when I got older his
handling skills was so [__]
unbelievable what he could do with a
ball and unless you see that right it's
really hard to explain right even if you
see Kobe Bryant pass or whether you know
Stefan Marbury pass it was nothing or
dribble the control that Pistol Pete had
for a White Guy it's and he had a tragic
life I don't think he ever won a
championship I don't think he ever won a
championship I know like I think he
still has like the highest average per
game for college yeah yeah cause he shot
90 times a [__] game his father
his father would say [__] those four
guys yeah literally a [__] ball shoot
the [__] those four [__] I
heard he even try to sometimes he would
wear a completely different Jersey like
he would be on a team and they'd play in
a team and then he'd show up in a total
different Jersey like I'm gonna play
both you guys and then be like you're
out of your [__] mind
it was nuts bro but uh yeah man we got
out to look for all types of Champs that
had gotten out of that uh out of that
joint you know you can still look for it
online they got some old stories about
you know it's crazy because
they had a lot of uh I was going sorry I
grew up in New York City but in my heart
after I saw different places
there was a couple places I wish I would
have grown up one would have been New
Orleans the other would have been
Houston
and there was one other place I wanted
to grow up when I was a kid I don't know
why New Orleans but I don't know why I
always thought New York would be really
cool you follow me like there's always
places like I'm very proud to be from
Jersey I love being from where I'm from
but it would be interesting like when I
go to New Orleans and I'm driving around
I always go hmm how would I turn down if
I would have grown up on this [__]
Street well I don't know about you but I
like I feel like the subject is a bad
rap up North but when I was driving I
drove across the country three times I
love this South I love it everyone's
nice yeah it's it has nice weather like
I felt like I got a bad rap where I was
in Mass people to [__] I don't know
people are chilled on there man
but it's a lot of the same like you hear
that you definitely notice it's a lot of
old-fashioned ideas down there like
people you know
concepts are slow you know but that's
what makes the South the South right
listen that's what makes the South the
South I read somewhere that last week
when those guys the terrorists shot
those people uh that the neighbor said
he suspected something but he didn't
want to call the police because he
didn't want to seem racist yeah Jesus
Christ because he was crazy politically
correct you understand we we got a point
in our lives we were too politically
correct look what happened yesterday
[__] Trump makes that announcement
against Muslims his [__] rating is
the highest it's ever been it's like 35
he's 20 points ahead of the [__]
competition 19 points ahead of that kind
of position I like uh you like sleepy
black
Ben Carson oh Jesus I can't vote so I
don't really know well you can't even
vote I got felonies and I don't want to
[__] vote it's too much pressure down
south I saw a brother take a bite out of
a Vietnamese guy once dude he took a
huge bite out of his [__] arm bro me
and everything bro ripped it right out
the Vietnamese guy was like threatening
him with all this karate [__] and
everything and his brother described
it think about it that's the way to do
it that stops karate all the time
because I don't care what type of karate
you got they got no defense for the bite
I'm saying nobody well what if a
[__] goes to bites it
hold on I gotta call it a main [__] and
[__] it okay
let me put my Komodo on dude and they
bite your ass dude
and you remember that every time you try
to [__] hug somebody and if you got a
little divot in it you know you got a
speed bump in your [__] hug why do
they let me talk me into mushrooms on a
Wednesday night like look at your head
look at me bro open your eyes bruh
you're already [__] up you gave me 800
before training I told you when you go
down the [__] when you join the Marines
and I'm singing to Miami you know with a
[__] seagull no they say you're the
[__] Paris Island debt what Marine
did they put in my own privacy yeah
I love it bro you got our own Marines
they come in all shapes and sizes amen
well enlist me he's got a use in the
Marines when you you know no I don't
yeah we'll get three dudes to throw you
into that [__] play glass window and
two guys in here you come flying through
with a helmet you don't know how much
damage you could do yeah Lee Lee
we'll put some shoulder pads on you and
a [__] helmet with no t-shirt on you
come through that window you have no
idea you thought that black dude scared
those three white kids You Ain't Seen
Nothing Yet with a SWAT stick on your
forehead with a beard nobody's gonna
stop you people will put their guns up
and go now yeah
this guy's got a SWAT stick on his head
with a helmet and a [__] pair of
shoulder pads he's showing up right he's
got bad intentions yeah
oh you should run for governor in that
outfit what's up Lee you have a good
time last night I had a great time last
night it was uh
it's fun like I've been in the last few
times because we they've done I think
they did one or two seasons of digital
and then this is the third season of
like TV and it's just like the people I
get to like I got to hang out with Steve
Simone all night but then like I saw
like Brian Regan was there which was
cool and Big Jay oakerson Big Jay
oakerson was there time last night Ari
show yeah last night a lot of people
just hanging out yeah you know and who
else was there when uh Josh Adam mines
had like six [__] with him ah eating
[__] uh uh you know set food yeah and
are you going up no he's just there with
six [__] he [__] said food that
combing his hair
like I just took the bus over for dinner
he don't give a [__] Josh Adam if it's a
comedy central event he's dead now he's
in my show got picked up I don't give a
[__] around here to sing a song
I Saw uh Vince Vaughn last night at the
uh Comedy Store too
he was just hanging out he went to him
see I guess him and Steve Burn his
buddies so he came out to hang out with
them and uh and then him and Sebastian
Maniscalco were talking for a long time
but he was super cool I went right up to
him because I did his Wild West Comedy
Fest last year so I'm right up to him I
was like Vincy
and he was super cool
yeah and then I was like I met your
sister last year at the comedy festive
one we talked for about 10 minutes he
was cool as hell man is uh anyway I said
I was just kind of cool with the store
but how uh I'm jealous I didn't get to
do the uh Ari show man this is a
showcase for it yeah did you showcase
her well it's at the score every Tuesday
he's upstairs oh I didn't know that just
asking Mario put me on no dog how many
stories you got yeah you got more
stories than most people forget in their
[__] life you know yeah man uh yeah
and it's [__] Feeling High I think I
watched I watched you're special and
it's tremendous my favorite part about
your special oh my God it's just you're
so goofy and it just goes like it goes
in ways like that's my favorite part
about Joey's Comedy is just sometimes
when it goes ways that you don't expect
right because like sometimes if you
watch enough stand-up comedy sometimes
you can just guess the punchline right
and when you can't and when it's
especially when it's so goofy which it
was great it was like because Joey and I
always talk whenever there's a new
special up we watch it we we discuss if
it's good yours is one of the only few
that's been you and Ellie won yeah we
won killed it too but yeah thanks man I
appreciate that dude especially coming
from somebody that's seen so many
comedians and it works with German I
appreciate that well the funny thing is
that you do your joke what we like
this is what I like I think some
sometimes that people have too much
respect for the punchline and it's not
really the punchline it's that little
stupid line you say afterwards and
listen
right now it's working today they ain't
nobody better than you saying that
little stupid line afterward because
that line that little stupid line
is a funnier thought that most people
get all day right and it's your inner
voice right I have the same inner voice
my inner voice cracks me up all day yeah
what you think is funny he's so [__]
bizarre and then you throw that last
little well you know and that that kills
it and people from the South do that
they have that last little three-word
[__] sense at the end of it that just
[__] makes the whole joke you know
yeah well you inspire me man after
seeing you over at the store dude like
because you just like because you're set
like something you're selling but like
my intention when I came out here was
never to sell jokes I wanted to be me
and then after I got caught up for a
long time everybody died I thought like
[__] and then nobody likes me I gotta
I gotta fit in just like everybody else
nope but then I saw you at the store one
night dude that [__] music went off
I'm like what is this going on I'm like
about to park a cruise ship on the
[__] wheel
I ripped everybody up a bunch of [__]
[__] instead today
you left I was like I am never not gonna
be myself again when you come out to Los
Angeles
you're here three months or you hit too
much
somebody's interested in you and they
take you to lunch and then they sign you
as a commercial agent or theatrical
agent or a manager
doesn't matter they're gonna send you
out for an audition for most people
don't know that could be any audition a
commercial audition
and the first words out of your mouth I
don't give a [__] if you're classically
trained is I I don't know what to do or
you're gonna say something their
response is going to be be yourself
and Eli thanks
and you hear that guys for [__] 15
years before one day you go
oh
I know what they want now yeah I wasn't
getting it the whole time I'm here I'm
trying to be Doug Stanhope I'm trying to
be Paul Mooney you're trying and I'm not
saying that I'm just saying yeah trying
to be Nick the problem trying to be a
Mitch Hedberg what if people go home and
go what if I could put Nick de Paulo and
Mitch Hedberg but the funniest character
that hiding
is the character they're hiding yeah
because that's the reason why they came
out here is because of that [__]
character that's gotten them through
everything for 15 years that voice yeah
that voice that you only let out in
front of your friends yeah and that your
friends like that is [__] hilarious
we're having a conversation at the store
one night you know like last week some
guy got fined with 30 pounds of hamster
bones you know they did in my town that
is busted a man it just doesn't right
away you gotta stop what you're doing in
that conversation and giggle because
nine out of 10 people wouldn't be proud
that that happened at their Hometown you
know what I'm saying like they wouldn't
even mention it if somebody comes up to
me and go ah are you from New Orleans
not really I'm from Texas wait a second
I gotta go you know you get to that
point most [__] people would be
embarrassed to say something like that
or it would take them 10 minutes after
everybody told their story yeah to say
oh by the way there's a guy no we've
been just talking
yeah we're ready to go home and you came
out with it and I'm [__] mentally
with dying in the car like what's he
talking about hamster meat what the [__]
is he talking about
[Music]
thank God
they got him no I'm glad they got him
dude 30 pound bag of hamster one like I
mean that's because you have to there's
not as much meat there's very little
bone in a hamster bro a ham probably has
like a quart like an eighth of an ounce
in his chest plate bro you can't even
make a wish on their bones you know
there's nothing in there where do you
get all those hamsters from that's well
they breed him in our town I used to
work for this group they used to sell
tattooed hamsters and guinea pigs after
uh they tattoo them yeah they used to
Brand them with concerts and Raves they
would say it's tattooed just to make
people not be as sad about it but it was
a brand
of what but like a heat and ink bruh for
what like what did it say uh 311 Green
Day anything like a different bands that
were coming to town Toadies
I swear to God bruh toady's Acid Bath uh
who else
Rave whatever we used to truck these
hands into the City and [__] just
vendum bro
we did man well because there wasn't
much there wasn't much work in our town
dude you know you had to get what you
could get and they had a man that bred
hamsters and uh and then they had to do
the tattoos and they [__] met up and
that was a merger that's big business
you know and they started uh
emerging they started doing it man I got
me some 300 miles in my house and [__]
and some other guy's like you know what
man I'm a pretty good tattoo artist
that means someone listening to this
right now has had a hamster with like a
band label on it
buys a hamster a [__] up dog those
Stars Hit me hard tonight that's what
happens you know why they hit me hard
cause I trained last week I didn't eat
Stars last week Lee sprayed out of his
face
at all I sprayed it but I'm still fine
beating stars and [__] [__] around I
had transmission no you didn't you threw
a chocolate away oh Jesus might have to
do everything on a periscope
Fearless man I'll see how you do it Lee
I really don't it's really not a good
choice anymore he does like a little bit
he goes like this in front of the camera
because I'm gonna eat some chocolate he
takes a bit like that he choosing in
this this 80 milligram whatever he
throws this away and he tells people he
ate it and tonight he ate the whole
thing and it was coming through his
[__] fingers you should have seen him
he was yelling out huh you know when you
were telling your story bro the thing
that
uh I was thinking about the most with
the 200 of those stories that I had that
I wish I had the time
I wish I had the [__] time to
and I got 10 that rolled around in my
head sometimes and one of them would pop
up
in the middle of night before I'm about
to fall asleep and my whole body
shatters bro
those are those type of stories it's
essentially when it comes to drugs yeah
especially when it comes to [__]
drugs
and you the next morning you wake up and
you're like that's [__] up I got my
life together I gotta call somebody and
[__] but you know ten days later it
happens again and you know and sometimes
it's it's sex so sometimes it's it's
crazy sex you go to a girl's house with
her son her sister and her stepfather in
the room yeah and everybody's banging
and you're like what the [__] am I a
part of you know I just want to watch
the [__] Nick games is that a real
scenario Lee you would be [__]
surprised what you bump out into when
you're out there yeah especially when I
started to do comedy you'd be surprised
my body was shaking yeah my body was
shaking just triple tours just Bolder
just you know
that I I thought life was a certain way
when I lived in New Jersey oh yeah I
remember boy was I [__] wrong I
remember trying to [__] this girl on
roller skates one time you ever try to
do that dude no at Halloween
unbelievable bro but that was drug
induced
I remember never been arrested
uh dude I got arrested in Mississippi
one time we're all high at some house
and they brought a kid the cops show up
and they brought a kid from downstairs
right and they said this kid is here
everybody's going in for contributing
delinquency of a minor
um
and then you could but once you got
outside kids were paying and getting out
of the thing they put us in the like the
slave shackles you know things they put
between two legs you know and then hook
you the person in front of you
uh
it wasn't that [__] dude and they would
have walked downstairs so it was the
dumbest thing ever bro it must have
taken us 40 minutes to get downstairs in
these [__] leg shackles with these
two stupid cops but they brought this
kid down and then later there was a
rumor that they were this was this kid
this was a stage kid they were high they
would pay in somebody's kid to [__]
they would sneak him in the back and put
them in people's houses and come down in
pajamas and then making money because
they're busting everybody in the house
because now they got a charge on
everybody contributed
um
what else did I go in before nothing
nothing real serious man well God bless
you man listen
but that was the thing I just wanted to
get I did I just yeah part of me was
like 86 you got a [__] career
you're on the upswing right now
you know what you [__] around you got
your dick sucked I'm not telling you to
uh go get married but it's time to start
watching your back because this is when
you're a good looking guy shows are
getting developed and written you could
be the number two dude pick up a check
five years no drama you know you already
did it yeah I've had so much fun bro you
know once you get everything out of the
way
this place becomes a complete different
animal yeah you know and listen Lindsay
Lohan survived it
uh the [__] Hilton kid survived it
some people don't yeah some people don't
man I told you when I walked in here
I'm not
I'm happy about the podcast I'm happy I
get to see Lee and we get high and we
talk [__] and and he makes a living and
I make a living and we sell tickets and
you know guys like you come on here and
people get to hear you
I like doing stand-up I don't think I
could do this [__] if I was doing blow
yeah there's no [__] way this this
podcast would have been dying with a
fell apart Lee would have been to Lee
wouldn't even have been talking to me no
more at this point Lee would have gone
and he left me there four [__] days
in a row you know who's gonna come out
of the house
yeah yeah and that was the thing I was
just like I just don't I need to take a
if this is where I'm kind of ending up
once in a while even once in a while I
just want to get it so nothing happened
after the cab ride after that that shook
you enough oh well with seeing Daryl
strawberries what shook me the next day
because he was 13 years sober and he was
like uh I mean this dude was eloquent he
had his life put together he's a
multi-millionaire now and then he was
pushing the the documentary 30 for 30
the new one with Doc Gooden but doc good
morning good and what couldn't show up
because he's so [__] up yeah he's all
[__] up and I know my life isn't their
lives but it made me think
okay you just gotta monitor what's going
on because I just I yeah I don't like to
I didn't like to party I just like to
put myself in a crazy situation yeah me
too you know I was that's what I was
thinking about the whole time you're
saying that I go yeah I don't miss the
drugs I missed the six o'clock on the
diner or waking up and some girl gives
you an Audi to drive home yeah you're
like what the [__] just happened last
night yeah dude I was in Louisville one
time I came out of a show they had a big
group and a limousine they invited me to
go to after party with them right I was
like I'm only coming if my boy can come
in like who's your boy and I'm like La
Cedric they had a brother nearby right
wearing this Louis Vuitton jacket dude
probably about 60 homeless right and
they're like that's your boy and I
didn't even talk to this dude right I
was like yeah that's my boy like all
right he can come so I [__] walk over
him looking right in the eyes and I was
like what's up man I'm Theo he's like
Cedric and uh I was like all right dude
I told these people you're my friend you
ever been in a limousine he's like no I
was like all right come get in with us
just act like you're my friend right
we're going to a party he's like all
right man so we go in the limo bro we're
in there hot chicks dudes people [__]
little Cedric kept saying we're friends
that's what he kept saying out loud
not the best actor bro what did we get
to this house party it's a nice cool
[__] party bro I'm downstairs I'm in
the kitchen somebody's making us a drink
I'm talking to somebody
[__] is six minutes later right here if
I can somebody scream I hear a window
break right
it comes running down they said some
dude just stole like four verses
out of the coat room upstairs and
[__] jumped out a window
that would have been me Doug
and that was [__] less Cedric bro
and that was like but and everybody
there was like crying and pissed
and some girl was like Furious because
all her tampons were in there or
something I remember she got pissed she
was a tough girl she was like one of
those uh what are those people that
slide the thing on the ice she said
curlers she was a curler
but I was in my head I was like this is
the best [__] night ever
no that's awesome so just [__] like that
where I just love to put life just in
precarious situations man get you black
on it you're never gonna mounted to
another house party ever oh I blacked
out one time here in Hollywood and that
scared me I woke up in my own bed had no
clue I got there I'd wet the bed I mean
I wet the bed while I was about 30
anyway did YouTube man filter until I
was like a teenager oh that's nothing
bro and uh and and that was a pretty
crazy night one second you were at the
Betsy with 13.
I'm gonna be honestly around there I
would guess yeah I gotta watch you like
a hook
those people are always awesome
it might have been a little bit like
maybe not 13 but close maybe 10 at least
well 10 ain't far from 13 if you're
talking at least
probably [__] no but yeah I know I
had a huge issue with it it was terrible
dude I used to I used to have those
buzzer underwear bro they put these
underwear on you when the urine would
hit them a buzzer would go off oh my God
I'm not joking look them up online this
ain't no joke bro so I went to my
grandparents my mother didn't tell them
that I had these right I'm really hoping
these are real singing not just a like a
torture device your parents but not at
all this doctor gave them to us dude
this dude was a bunch of Google this
dude was a Bonafide doctor so we went
there I got the electric pants on dude
you know
would you like Google I'm getting my
rest probably uh you know buzzer
underwear for urinators Google buzzer
underwear for urinators
um and uh so then but they didn't tell
my grandfather right
so he [__] had a small house bro
little bitty house
so my [__] crotch is just but like he
he wakes up middle of the night dude
you're on fire I'm not on fire but I'm
buzzing hard bro because that had apple
juice man and I pissed big on apple
juice dude I [__] spray out on the AJ
so I'm in there just buzzing dude I
didn't know and he came in he still got
him yeah hit me up at least
give me a pack he didn't know what was
going on oh my God he comes in he's
scared bro how is it
how loud is this in a little bitty house
you could you could hear it from down I
just want to wake my wife up in the
middle of night like twice a week I
would just do two drops and you and it
goes off
and uh and so my grandfather's in there
right and he's all scared and [__] and
uh oh this would have been terrible when
I was a kid and he's pushing me with a
broomstick dude he thought I was dead
dude he didn't know what had happened
and we thought his possessed or dead
he's pushing me with a broomstick to
wake me up and he was worried because he
had one of those heart makers and uh he
was worried he would get electrocuted he
thought something was happening he
thought the house had short circuited
into the phone company it [__] up
that's what he thought the phone company
ah so he thinks I'm [__] just laying
there buzzing like this is a [__]
mystery but he died man my grandfather
ended up
oh he died I love people I love laughing
I love laughing this [__] like this you
can't write this I forgot about that
I did man
this has been the Batman I appreciate
you had me on because I've been I was
sick the past two days man what was
wrong with you
oh man I had adult diarrhea bro to be
honest it happens those [__] flights
you're eating [__] Katrina leftovers
though yeah they still got some guys got
in stock oh they're serving [__]
crippled Pig [__] down there front I
was eating about a handful [__]
around down that track
oh my God I'm high on those stars
because like I said
I hate [__] transmission fluid and a
couple of these Moon things they're not
that killed the cookies was done I ate
the transmission fluid and the moon
thing and I was home all night with my
oh my God I [__] killed those cookies
I want some cookies man dude I ate half
of a pot cookie one time I never had one
there's a couple years ago I invited
this casting director right out to a
comedy show
she comes but the comedy show was the
next night I had the nights wrong so I
felt bad and she was cute I was like
well at least I'll get her dinner
because she came all this way I didn't
want to be like a you know just like you
said like a mooc you know so buy this
lady dinner we're sitting there eating
dinner she gave me a pot cookie
and I got high man I never had one and I
didn't know how we knew each other and
it was like a nice restaurant and I
started thinking that this was like my
girlfriend you know I was like [__] dude
I'm the work and uh I tried to make a
move on about a cab stand dude and she's
like what the [__] are you doing you
know
and uh she wasn't my girlfriend man
and uh anyway
that was it
that was it dude but uh yeah yeah Subs
dangerously I think it's what I'm
getting at here
by the way my suspension on Facebook is
over my suspension on Facebook is over
my suspension on Facebook is over
thank God they were trying to [__] with
me those people God damn them but no man
I'm very proud of the year that you've
done this has probably been a tough year
for them for you I know you work on
yourself or not I know you suffer from
anxiety like I do when you deal with it
yeah and how many millions you're going
to a week I'm probably going uh
four are you [__] them up at the maze
you make them laugh sometimes but
sometimes I gotta be careful not to get
caught up in that kind of stuff because
you know I want to make sure that I'm
being a part of what's going on no
you're just a funny guy just talking so
I can yeah but sometimes yeah people
start talking you know the other day
you know there's a black guy in my
building always calling me the n-word
and stuff and I'm telling them about
that and how It's upsetting me and
people are laughing and so sometimes you
just let me know what people are gonna
laugh at you know but
but I mean yeah I go and it's good man
it's a good sense of Brotherhood I mean
some of the reason I get in there is I
need some structure in my life you know
that was the thing like I never had
anybody like my whole life I've made
every decision no one's ever told me
anything to do or any why to do
something or not to I mean I I think
I've never had anybody I've never
listened to anybody or cared to really
so you know a lot of that I'm just
learning how to coexist with others and
to listen other people to take Direction
um and you know sometimes I feel like a
kid again but sometimes I feel like more
like a man you know
and it's a journey bro and I'm happy to
be on it like I'm one of those people
that kind of I feel like I want to
experience everything a little bit you
know which may be one of the reasons why
I even used to do cocaine or party you
know like I would put myself in Crazy
situations because I just wanted to
have a story or I wanted to experience
you know I just want to I just want that
I want to be a part of the story I just
want something that I need something you
know so it's nice to try and not need
something and just be but you checking
in with me man makes me feel good and
you know it's things like that that make
me feel supported and stuff like that
and I appreciate it man and even just
getting to know you know I've met some
neat people through you and getting to
know you and uh it's inspiring also to
see some [__] hammers on the stage
again you know no more of these joke
writing mathematicians let's get some
[__] slinging dick out there and
let's see some entertainers bro I'm sick
of this you need to support entertainers
man quit supporting all these [__]
Muppets you know you got away with words
brother sometimes I'm learning from you
tonight man and it's good to see you Lee
bro I always love seeing you I'm
disappointed I'm happy for you that
you're going to uh Montreal but I'm
going to Vegas and then next week so
disappointed but next time would have
been there together thanks go to Vegas
Friday it's your birthday this Friday
correct Thursday yeah nice are you gonna
be 29 years old you know yes sir you
know that that uh people at home know
that I torment them with the Edibles I
explained myself last week that
if I didn't do these things there's a
part of me that looks at Lee and he
knows I love him to death
and I'm happy he has a girlfriend
it bothers me when he talks about
marriage you know because he's not ready
at all by no means you know that's true
he'll be ready on these 30 4 35 he has
to play this hand out here and see if he
wants to open up his own business
but the other part I always wanted Lee
to do something you know he's not the
type that's going to crisscross across
Thailand like uh Ari shaffir yeah well
he's
you know so the last
five years I've been trying to get Lee
to find something
that's an adventure a little extra yeah
a little something they threw him off
the [__] line there
zip line people keep sending me let's
not bring it up we don't need to open up
all sorts but it's weird
you know what
I look at my wife sometimes it's pitiful
last night I laid down and I thought of
part of my life it was so disturbing I
actually had to get up with my robot and
go in the [__] office and sit there
for an hour I'll actually [__] think
like a valium or xanax a little white
2.5
because I thought about something I
don't know how I'm gonna attack
something I did in my past and I could
either avoid it or confront them in the
next year or so and explain what I did
why
and maybe uh who the [__] knows
and I'm tight with this person I feel
[__] horrible you know what I'm
saying that I have to confront them and
[__] I bet they'll understand man I
think anybody would understand coming
from you you know
is that a [__] bad time and uh
people do weird [__] things yeah I
get it I [__] get it big time
there's times in your life a divorce
[__] like that
that I went through I I didn't I didn't
know that
I found out years later that uh even the
divorce [__] me up a little bit that
made me do well a couple little [__] and
uh I'll land this type thing you know
so I want to go straighten up with them
and uh
That's it man I'm just trying to put the
pieces together just like you brother
good for you man I'm happy you got your
One thanks I went 10 without blow
dude that's huge man that is huge if you
[__] think
I remember there was a time that I had
accepted it like in 93 once I accepted
comedy I said listen part of this comedy
deal is I'm not gonna fight this in the
demon no more this [__] again high
and then for four days shaking and not
it's not worth the aggravation and he's
a mental I'm out I got no
responsibilities I got zero
responsibilities I'm a nomad I live on a
pager I got a P.O box in Boulder and I
got a 400 a month apartment that's my
bills I had a 500 a month nut I had a
[__] car that all you had to do was
change the oil and it talk yeah that
became a [__] Nomad you know what I'm
saying and part of that no matters
that all those songs you hear about life
on the road and wanted Dead or Alive by
Bon Jovi or yeah that's what it became
for me to become a [__] solid comic
you got to go back to fundamentals and
sometimes you got to go to hell and do
comedy and really like I came out of
here and I thought I was Johnny slick
from Seattle and I had enough to do
spots at the store
at one o'clock when I didn't really have
I got eaten alive at The Improv yeah
between Doug Stanhope and Nick depalo I
felt and I saw all the holes in my game
and I knew to get those holes clean you
got to go to hell Buffalo you got to go
to all those towns and once you rock
them you come back to LA in a year yeah
and see what happens
that's a training camp yeah and I just
took everything I could Michigan Ohio
Atlanta yeah that's what I've been doing
Tampa you know I would do whatever I
could but Myrtle Beach and I lived week
to week every Monday I sent out faxes
200 100 faxes and I get a week somewhere
by Tuesday I get a week somewhere
[__] Theo Von it was crazy
there was somewhere I got a week in fact
I was just telling I was in St Louis
last week
and I went there the year before and I
went to the year before with Ari
but before that I hadn't been in St
Louis
since
2000. wow I was on the road living like
a mono man with this Broad
me and this brother on the road as a
headline a feature Act
we're not [__] but we're [__] like
Savages and snorting blower yeah but
we're actually sleeping in separate
hotel rooms but I would stay and hurt
the hotel room until five we'd do
everything she was crazy I loved I still
do
and we got a call from Roger Paul
you know that is in New York I think I
was a kind of week fee in St Louis
call me back how much is it 500
the feature gets 250. that's it in those
days
we were like in [__] Miami yeah we
got in that car and drove up to Fairview
Heights Illinois it was a hotel and then
there they had a comedy club that was
part of a Yoda run Yoda also booked the
the owner booked it I think the guy's
name was Paul
[__] Johnny Bananas over there Lee
knows the broad I'm talking about
we walk in that place on a Wednesday
it's Wednesday through Sunday you know
those places give you three beers a
night those places give you three beers
a night
I got a hook up for Coke as soon as I
got there somebody at the club had with
740s for you know it was like seven
tenths of a gram and I would I got an
advance of 200 bucks I figured I'd walk
with 300 200 would last me a whole week
they gave you free breakfast at the
hotel yeah the club gave you dinner so
all I had to scavenger for in those days
was a lunch which is a Subway veggie and
cheese I wouldn't like those days you
know what I'm saying bag of chips a
combo was a [__] big day like you got
a combo full and sometimes I have to get
the 12 inch and eat the one for lunch
and the other one for dinner yeah so if
I had Guinness to eat one 12 inch for
largely those are big time days right
there I was living big you know what I'm
saying I got a 12 inches and [__] like
that living live oh my God a fancy car
do I [__] jump up and down and jiggle
for Love at this point in my life you
know me a long time bro I got my own
views I live my own [__] life I don't
give a [__] about what you know
directors and producers think before you
came here you're a [__] man and you
got to leave here [__] man yeah if
you become what they want you to become
those are the [__] people that
never came here
they never should have came here
yeah those stories I told last night at
the Ice House on stage they're true
stories I totally gotta go [__] himself
on the set of this [__] Highline
commercial like I shot this Arby's what
is it again are you sure you want me to
say it no what's the name of parties
Hardies oh I love Hardee's bro what's
the name of the cousin to Hardee's oh
Carl's James Carl's Jr so years ago
Bryce shot three National commercials
three weeks in a row
like in my 20 years here that's here I
booked like 10 commercials but in 2009
two thousand one of those years
I booked a [__] three National Sprint
wow something else and this Arby's which
was [__] money yeah because they pay
you from both companies and they make my
ads together you have no [__] ideally
dude I did a shitty internet commercial
one time I made 25 Grand over three
years
bro how many crazy how many people stand
in front of a cup with 7-Eleven 25 Grand
over three years is a gift oh it was a
gift I couldn't imagine I thought I was
gonna make six hundred dollars you know
I could never imagine that would have
made that much money over that time oh
yeah and they give you a little I told
Lee for a year and I'll leave stop this
[__] go get your head shots go give that
guy four dollars go to Aqua tell them
you want to go out for commercials Jesus
Christ I wanted to put you in some [__]
her she kisses snacks anything anything
that people eating jumping up and down
gas with a jersey on you're wanna do you
know you're a zombie looking
[__] you know what I'm saying
yeah you could be the friend got a chest
bro you're right [__] a dog guarding the
condoms dude or [__] sitting there
with some [__] on your leg
and then just focus on Commercial and I
was like you know what I think it's time
for Uncle Joey to get a commercial agent
again yeah because I'm gonna book a
mafia commercial once a year or a cook
or a chef or a pizza guy or a garbage
man yeah if you don't if you're not in
the game you're never gonna book the
game yeah I signed with a chick and we
let I get paperwork that I gotta put my
bank account information on there and I
go what do you need my background
information before
she goes well if we ever need together
you gotta take that off the contract
Papa just gives you a name and a
headshot go to work [__] yeah and then
we'll worry about [__] bank
information Social Security numbers suck
my dick I gotta give you a credit report
who the [__] are you let me see your
credit report [__] I thought veggies
made you fart all the time not me man
you clean You're Sober you look good
you're the adult you're gonna shoot a
special what do you want to do
I think we're gonna do one more Showtime
we'll see if not dog listen
you see that I'm right there
that's uh what's his name he sold a
bunch of those
and you know what bro you get yourself
away you throw away a couple of Dimes
we put together a little team you take
it to the Irvine Empire we blow it up on
a few podcasts do it at ice house and
you do two shows it doesn't matter
materials material and guess who owns
the material who's got the money on
[__] light tones yeah you do when you
monitor it and you know what this whole
business is Media anyway
how many people have free internet and
how many people have showed them let's
let's take a [__] vote yeah you know
what I'm saying so if it's gonna be
Showtime you're gonna sell yourself for
Showtime [__] it you know what let me go
let me put a [__] our mouth you put
pictures in there you light in case
[__] on fire yeah you with your
buddies at The Comedy Store Wall come
down and support you doing it tonight
when we're all in town
people rather have that in a [__] CD
and guess what you're the Captain Kirk
of the Enterprise and you run it because
you know these people are going to
listen to you at work and laugh their
ass off yeah more than they're gonna tap
into Showtime goal and oh yeah I agree
you're making them go to places they
ain't there and you know what they love
you to dead man
he went to Showtime [__] him yeah I'll
go to somebody who's on iTunes for 2.52
sites and I can listen to that work and
giggle and what about the video could we
also put the video on iTunes you think
Lee yeah absolutely you can do whatever
[__] you want with the video I'd rather
you control it I'd rather you pay that's
what I think well you pay the G note let
them get the video and then pay another
number and let them get a a g note and
uh let them get the video and the behind
the scenes with Lee and dust and smoking
reefer you going home and showing your
father's grave and you bowing and yeah
let's go show me the camper will you
assist the strip the first time and
locate let's go see what they're doing
today low ceiling dude they're
developing a bunch of surface strippers
suck my dick they're all doing that
what's up man like my [__] like my dad
Batman
what were some of your Halloween
costumes when you were young dude
um
one of them was probably Batman you
couldn't even have a [__] a Boy Scout
couldn't even be next to me because
those in those days you were flammable
as [__] when I was a kid people used to
light on fire on Halloween all the time
for no [__] reason though
you go to school on a Tuesday the next
day they come in with bandages and a Jar
full of Vaseline and no eyebrows what
happened to you were you letting people
on fire no just a wild night dude listen
if a car was driving okay people don't
spontaneously combust oh because they
did buy those suits they were made by
some material kerosene dog this [__] was
blowing up so let's say you were walking
me you CEO we got a couple idiots with
10 we're walking across the street with
our little [__] there's people who
make costumes yeah but then there were
parents who bought them they came in a
box and they came with a mask on top of
the phone the master cut your [__]
skin The Mask would cut your skin it was
like razor blades it was for tough kids
yeah and then the suit you were gonna
live when your mom gave you that suit
she signed them for the Liberty National
Insurance
because let me say let me put it to this
way
you're crossing the street you got the
hand that goes like this you know right
right but at that first light there's a
car and by mistake it's like a 1966
Chevelle if it backfires you're going up
the flames you know what I'm saying dude
they had some textiles going around our
area that had Carousel and I wish Lee I
was lying kerosene in the cloth yeah you
were burned he will burn up every
Christmas you see a group of kids one of
them with like a flash suit of Batman
you're like that kid's not going to
school a little more yeah somewhere
along the line those poor bastards were
[__] combust Chevy Blazers would
always do a fire off too at the end you
know my uncle used to get out and run
back to the back of the car and it would
go off and he would act like it shot him
you know when he'd fall on the ground
because a lot of those cars would
backfire and they had a lot of clothing
back in our area somebody was making bad
clothing had kerosene in it and kids
were [__] getting uh
adults too a lot of adult men we were
smokers we're getting burnt out
hilarious I forgot all about those
[__] remember the boxes I forgot
about them you forgot about the Box they
and they had all different sizes all
different colors and they were called
take your chance Halloween make it a
real Halloween make it a Rooney the
other days people who want to get scared
you want to be Halloween shove a dick
and yes and get a mirror in front of
your face and look at the reflection of
your mouth open you'll be scared how is
this company more around for more than
one year
if you said like they went to states
where they endorsed [__] dude they
have doors [__] uh what do you call
those people
are you
dude they had a girl in her neighborhood
dude she would put that mask on and her
head was so big it would like smash her
face in like a shape with like a cookie
right and it would take three days even
after she took the mask off it would
take like three days for a [__] face
to go back to form
brooney dude this girl looked like
[__] Mickey Rooney bro I I told you
when I was growing up you were growing
up every day you live for you you
struggle for your life whether you're
rich or not because those are the kids
who bought those little half of facts
where those kids that had the flammable
[__] Batman suits and [__] the kids
that just like I put a sheet on my head
one year and yeah you know whatever
everybody's a [__] ghost I'm a loser
one year I was a garbage man when you
guys are [__] abortion you know I'm a
[__] student but yeah you put a [__]
over your ass with a [__] hanger
around your neck you're not you know
like a [__] [__] yeah like an
Italian nun yeah so that that's what you
know
so that was the [__] story I dressed
up before I I probably got dressed up
[__] four times and 54 [__] years
yeah I wasn't a big Halloween dude that
dressing up [__] scares me
yeah this week scares the [__] on me man
[__] Wednesday is dealing with those
dude I went this weekend to Hollywood
Forever Cemetery yeah you people you
people do it the right way you go up
there you think somebody's gonna come
out with a boom mask on I think I go
deep into the voodoo world yeah I go
deep I don't like candles I put a cigar
out I'll probably put some Cuban food
out for these [__] Spirits this week
and drove them crazy I got some guineas
on there I gotta take care of this I
gotta get a meatball for them from rails
or something
I got some Irish people I got to put a
shot of whiskey out for them you got the
oil please you gotta have the [__] uh
the [__] Altar for you people who
[__] kept you alive over the years
I got balzano Rago Dominic special I got
[__] uh Jesus my mother my father my
godmother I got Zoraida my stepfather he
could burn in hell I don't give a [__]
about that come on dude yeah I don't
toast them for dick anymore I used to
toast them get them a donut or something
you could just toast so many people you
know what I'm saying I got people dying
left in got Ralphie now I gotta get a
picture of Ralphie and put like a
[__] jalapeno Papa out of respect for
that [__] [__] sucker left me here
with these [__] Gentiles cow cow oh I
had a rough time yeah a nice podcast
because he showed up to the office the
other night Wednesday night yes we heard
we heard the horn go we were talking
about him we were talking about him I go
you know who gamer Stanley that speaker
he gave it to me wow look how long ago
it was it was by that company that you
get a magazine strawberry and Sharper
Image oh yeah my house on the box I
didn't even know what the [__] it was I
go honey I got this in the mail she goes
Ralphie sent the tea it's an iPad iPod
charger I still got the I'm so old
school I still got that iPod I brought
that here because the speakers are
Sensational and right as we were talking
about it you felt like a little breeze
and all of a sudden I could feel I could
just remember him he was just there
three [__] weeks ago four weeks ago
sitting there
and the [__] Mexican fruit guy came
and goes
and Ralphie always would go pick a
papaya pick up papaya for years
Ralphie's been saying that [__] whenever
you play that and dude yeah first of all
everything he said is exactly how it
went down but also we're here every
night that truck that's that sound is
never here it's always it you came by to
say goodbye that's reality guys they
stick around for 30 days they just don't
go into [__] the next image they want
to see your friends one last time and
touch you and listen bro I had a friend
Jimmy Burkle that I loved
on that Friday he was in the hospital
already
and he's like Coke sometime but I could
tell his voice he was done he had fight
he would wrestle with kids
and I never forget getting a call that
Sunday saying he died Sunday morning and
[__] he was saying goodbye man when
Karma and I was anal died I missed his
call
when I called him back he was dead wow
a day later Frankie called he goes yeah
your phone you just called him
he must have just gone to the bathroom
got up and died of a heart attack damn
they call you to say goodbye everybody
says goodbye believe it or not they all
say goodbye in their own way and if you
talk to people who've had somebody die
recently
give them 30 days they give you a signal
before they leave just to let you know
that they got you back it's the weirdest
thing about life
yeah I believe that man they'll give you
and I know it sounds crazy I'm talking
about Flat Earth and whatever I'm
talking about the spiritual world
I was raised in it so I get it I believe
that my dad opens up a lot of doors for
me and closed a lot of the doors I was
there a lot of nights man when I had a
lot of choices to run
and I always made the right choice and
that I wouldn't be in this [__] chair
something makes you make the right
choice yeah something
all right
[Music]
thank you